be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
so because I can't make a trailer
reaction for the Batman vs Superman
trailer due to copyright issues instead
what I wanted to do here was have a
discussion on the history of their
battles and why it is that DC brings the
two into conflict so infrequently
in 1939 with the critical success of Joe
Shuster and Jerry Siegel Superman the
fledgling comic book industry found
itself on the cusp of a new generation
of entertainment media but also in a
sort of quagmire if Superman changed the
definition of heroes in terms of how
they are represented in literature and
if his popularity had effectively taken
the world by storm how could his
popularity be matched in an effort to
answer this question as well as gain a
foothold and the increasing popularity
of comic books writer bill finger and
artist Bob Kane created Batman while
Batman's early concept are depicted his
physical appearance in a far different
manner than what we know him to be today
one thing that didn't change was the
basis for his character and contrast to
Superman's incredible feats of strength
endurance and various powers due to his
alien physiology Batman was simply a man
who was victim to a tortured past with
no real superpowers of his own
Batman would rely on a combination of
his intelligence wealth and by extension
various gadgets and technologies in
order to fight crime in Gotham but
furthermore Batman's outlook on the
world was a total 180 from Superman in
that batman was ruled by his past his
inability to let go of the loss of his
parents govern his every decision in
relation to friends and partners the
Superman on the other hand was the last
of his kind
while both had a personal understanding
of how quickly life could be lost
the Superman chose not to take a darker
outlook on life and instead cherished
the possibility of what people could
become regardless of the philosophical
differences between the two characters
however due to Batman's popularity
rivaling Superman's it became obvious to
fans creators and the world at large
that the time would eventually come when
the two would have to meet while the New
York World's Fair anthology comic in
1940 depicted Superman Batman and Dick
Grayson as Robin on the cover the story
itself had no true interaction between
the group instead the comic was a 96
page collection of stories involving the
team of Batman
as well as Superman fighting crime and
the respective cities as we discussed in
previous videos on the history of comics
as the 1940s turned into the 1950s
leading up to the 1960s the element of
superheroes began to fade away with only
a handful like Superman and Batman
surviving the survival of Superman and
Batman was due in part to their
popularity but also because of the
events depicted and Superman issue
number 76 in 1952 while this story did
not feature a battle between either
Batman or Superman what it did feature
was a team-up with both individuals
vacationing at the same time aboard the
same cruise liner
they eventually joined forces to defeat
a criminal on board where this story was
relatively lackluster in terms of any
major conflict this story is largely
attributed as the first time that Bruce
Wayne and Clark Kent met and by
extension revealed their identities to
one another
now following the reception of a team-up
between Superman and Batman the New York
World's Fair titles were renamed to
world's finest providing readers with
various stories of both Superman and
Batman fighting crime and gotham
metropolis or other locations across the
world while this story helped to keep
Superman and Batman in the spotlight of
comic readers amidst the growing
popularity in science fiction stories
the combined efforts of DC in the early
1950s and Marvel in the 1960s led to a
revitalization of the superhero industry
and comics however the establishment of
the comics code Authority and their
implementation of rules on comic
creation forced these heroes into a more
lighthearted tone what I mean is that
while Superman's character did not see
an extreme change
Batman's character did Batman's cruel
demeanor from his early issues was swept
away in support of a more
family-friendly depiction portraying him
as occasionally goofy and never really
willing to kill however as time passed
and the comics code Authority was
lightened leading up to its outright
elimination society itself was beginning
to move into territory where darker
stories were welcomed as a break away
from the archaic standards that had
existed for almost 40 years this desire
for more tangible characters paired with
DC's continuity reboot with
is on Infinite Earths the paved the way
for DC to give fans exactly what they
wanted a meeting between Superman and
Batman
that wasn't light-hearted but instead
resulted in a fight
you
in February of 1986 during the last days
of DC's crisis on Infinite Earths event
early writer and artist Frank Miller
presented us with the Dark Knight
Returns initially being presented as a
standalone story isolated from any main
continuities The Dark Knight Returns
provided us with a world ten years into
the future where Batman came out of
retirement at 55 years old to fight
crime in a version of Gotham City that
was rampant with criminals while the
story depicts Batman fighting alongside
Carrie Kelly operating as this reality's
version of Robin the Batman goes against
everyone from street level criminals to
the Joker himself eventually the story
leads up to a conflict with Superman
operating as an agent of the government
and weakened after stopping a nuclear
weapon from exploding over gotham city
itself while the battle between the two
stretches across Gotham with Batman
using every resource available to him
including the city's power grid as well
as Armour explicitly designed a combat
Superman due to the help of Oliver Queen
and a well-timed Green kryptonite arrow
Batman eventually comes out on top this
story and all this complexity is
considered one of the greatest stories
not only for Batman but for the comic
book industry as a whole the reason for
this is because it marks a change
between the previous standard of light
headed stories involving Batman as
Superman to grim and darker stories
recognizing the cash cow that came with
a fight between Superman and Batman DC
also recognized the importance of case
as a company that focused heavily on
consistent individual story arcs rather
than massive crossover events DC had to
ensure that conflicts between characters
were introduced in a manner that seemed
plausible without being forced as a
result while future stories including
1990s world's finest vol 2 1999 zr7
a better world as well as Superman and
Batman generations depicted the duo as
being at odds but not fighting in 2003
DC released a story of hush in this
story Batman is besieged by an onslaught
of attacks at the hands of his most
formidable enemies who have been
organized by a mysterious villain named
hush while the war against Batman
includes his entire gallery of villains
it also includes Superman himself
where the initial events of the story
lead to a partnership in romance between
Batman and Catwoman their efforts lead
them to metropolis where they learn the
Superman is under Poison Ivy's control
performing a plan with Catwoman and
luring Superman into the sewers below
The Daily Planet
Batman dons a ring with green kryptonite
after stating that laser vision will
ignite the gas from the main that has
been ripped open the Superman is forced
to fight Batman hand to hand while
Batman is able to hold his own in the
battle the Catwoman initiates her part
of the plan by kidnapping Lois Lane and
taking her to the top of the Daily
Planet the throwing her off the top of
the building Superman snapped out of his
mind control and rescues Lois Lane now
with the completion of another
anticipated battle between the two under
their belt DC look to the idea of having
Batman come into conflict with Superman
yet again but in a more roundabout way
to this end DC launched the Justice
League story of the Tower of Babel in
2003 in this four-part series
Rachele Ghul steals Batman's character
profiles on the Justice League these
files as they were maintained by Batman
outlined ways to defeat each Justice
League member should they become
uncontrollable and threaten the safety
of each other or the world with these
files in hand
Rachele Ghul begins his conquest of the
Justice League by subjecting each member
to the profile as it was outlined by
Batman while able to take out each
member of the Justice League in
sequential order starting with a Martian
Manhunter Superman is the last one to be
taken down using the information
provided by Batman rich al Ghul subjects
Superman to Batman's experimental red
kryptonite which turns his skin
transparent in addition to this the
solar energy that powers Superman is
exposed directly to the nervous system
of his body rather than being filtered
through his skin this is effectively an
adrenaline shot to Superman sending his
powers into overdrive his five senses
his laser vision strength and the like
are all multiplied several times over
now while Superman is eventually able to
overcome once the effects of the
Kryptonite wear off along with the rest
of the Justice League this story
highlights one major feat for Batman his
sole knowledge of how to take down an
incapacitating GLE member of the Justice
League including Superman himself enough
following the Tower of Babel
and going forward with stories like
Batman Superman Public Enemies smoke and
mirrors and a handful of dots DC
continued the trend of keeping Batman vs
Superman battles as a scarce appearance
with a to more commonly coming to the
brink of a fight but never actually
engaging in one however as it seemed to
be both customary and timely with DC's
relaunch of its lineup with the new 52
reboot the new volume of the Justice
League under Jeff John saw the duo come
into conflict with one another yet again
with this new continuity establishing
that all of these heroes are meeting for
the first time the conflict between
Batman and Superman seems more of a
curiosity or tests of each other's might
rather than an actual conflict of malice
regardless of the reasons for these
conflicts between the two both of the
publication histories have established
that in any given story at any given
time the duo may find themselves coming
directly into conflict at which point
fans will tear through the comics with
rapt anticipation asking the questions
what are they fighting for and will
Batman win
with that being said we're going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it
then I will catch you guys later peace